finally
the gold medal
it goes to a film made at the national
film and television school in the united
kingdom i might add that this film is a
first in the foreign film category this
is the first time in 33 years that a
foreign film winner has been an animated
film
we'll actually be showing this film in
its entirety in just a few minutes as
we'll be screening all of the gold medal
winning films at the conclusion of our
presentation but for now
please welcome the director of the film
miss todd christina yee
so um i think we can also congratulate
ourselves on being the most american
foreign film to ever win in the foreign
film category
for a brief explanation i i went to film
school in england so hence the accent
i'm actually from california
so
but to begin with the thank yous first
of all i and i can't believe that i i'm
actually getting to say this i would
like to thank the academy
for the absolutely amazing week that
we've had we've had such an amazing time
we've met amazing people
we've been fed amazing food
and
and i've met amazing filmmakers and i
just want to congratulate all of my
fellow award winners because i found all
of your films to be incredibly inspiring
and
and i just i hope to see you all as as
peers in the film industry now that
we're no longer students
um secondly i'd like to thank the
national film television school and all
of the wonderful tutors that i had there
it was such an amazing place to be in
such an incredibly creatively nourishing
environment and i absolutely loved it
there
i'd like to thank my family especially
my parents who had to
deal with their daughter deciding that
instead of a lawyer she wanted to be a
filmmaker and an animator no less
so thank you so much for all of your
support i want to thank my husband robin
wennery who's
out there in london now so i married an
englishman so maybe that makes me a
little bit more foreign
um and
most importantly i would like to thank
the cast and crew of miss todd
especially our our wonderful female
vocalist
and
just the crew who are supremely
supremely talented people most of whom
are here tonight and i'm going to have
to to name them all and actually if you
guys could stand up i would just love
for everyone to be able to see you too
because you are the true
the true stars of this film fran
palletti writer
nick cook cinematographer izona ragao
production designer michaeli chiapa
editor
matt kelly composer
tom lock griffiths sound designer
cam baines rsfx supervisor
susie major our our producer and so and
pallavi dave who's our artistic
supervisor
and a few people who aren't here tonight
phil chapman georgia orwell and laura
miskovic but thank you so much and and
to my incredible crew i have loved
working with you so much and i'm the
luckiest director in the world thank you
everybody thank you so much